foreign the forces of healing
reconciliation and shared interest that
have inspired the construction of Europe
are today increasingly transforming the
economic and political landscape of the
island of Ireland
[Music]
my visit here to the European Parliament
comes at a time of great hope and
optimism on the island of Ireland
for the first time in a generation
it's free of parliamentary violence
it's right to express here in this city
so symbolic of the spirit of European
reconciliation deep appreciation for the
consistent and unwavering support of the
European Union unemployment and poverty
are like poisons which attack the social
fabric failure to devise the and
Implement radical solutions to these
problems undermines confidence
with power comes responsibility and as a
corollary to the importance and
influence in the world the union is
bound to exercise those powers in a
responsible fashion we owe it to those
much less fortunate than ourselves to
provide the means with which they can be
freed from the debilitating cycle of War
famine and disease it's incumbent on us
to ensure that the causes and
consequences of hunger and suffering in
the developing world are properly
addressed
the old certainties have vanished with
the collapse of communism a unique
historical opportunity has presented
itself however it's also important that
relations with Russia should be based on
respect for human rights and the
principles of the United Nations and the
osce Ismael is all done
thank you for giving me this opportunity
[Music]
foreign